you talked earlier about having this
dream of playing for Barcelona and it
did turn out to be a nightmare and
probably the main reason for that was
the breakdown in your relationship with
the manager Pep Guardiola who right now
many would say is the best coach in the
world you had a very different
experience with him uh you called him a
coward with no balls uh you said when
you buy me you're buying a Ferrari if
you drive a Ferrari you put premium
petrol and a tank you hit the motorway
and you step on the gas guarda filled up
with diesel and took a spin in the the
countryside he should have bought a
fat I think Guardiola is an amazing
coach when I was there the coaching was
different compared to what I had before
he totally on a different level that's
why he's successful because if you see
on his
career if you take the last 15 10 to 15
years the guy never came third place
he's always first or second so the coach
is amazing and uh but I had a different
situation with him because I had the
coach and I get to to meet the person
and we it became a problem a problem I I
was not aware of because I solve my
problems I look in the eyes doesn't mean
I have to like you or dislike you we
will solve it and it takes one second to
solve it we go straight and we solve it
but solve a problem if the problem is
between two persons it takes two to to
solve it and especially when the other
side doesn't know when I remember when I
was there I was like because before I
came to Barcelona always media have
their input and saying they would go
like you don't fit in here you don't fit
in the culture it's different different
because who I
was and my mistake was there I Tred to
fit in instead of being who I am because
I think is important like I begin the
interview being who you are is being
perfect but there I tried to be somebody
I was not and I said to him listen if I
have twoo big nose for you you tell me
if I walk strange you tell me if I'm not
good enough you tell me if you don't
like whatever I do you tell me I resolve
the problem I leave I'm not here to
disturb I'm need I'm not here to create
I'm just here to F fulfill my dream and
uh and I didn't hear nothing about it
the the thing was it kept kept first 6
months was okay everything was good no
but the strange thing the first meeting
I had with him was like
remember players here don't come with
Ferrar Porsche and that then it it felt
like why he's already judging you but
why you call me every day to bring me
here and then you want to send this
message to me don't worry I will not
bring my car and I didn't bring it
didn't bring it for six seven eight
months and then I started
to the directors because I I would
perform bad and the the people above him
would complain but they said we cannot
engage if you don't open the door so I
would have to go to him and say listen
what's going on so I create a situation
so the people above him could interfere
because they could not interfere if
there was nothing and I went to him
listen can I talk a friendly talk like
simple even I wrote it in the in the
book I say I said to him listen I'm not
doing good I think with the situation
with Messi putting him I need more space
you brought me in so I need my space to
do my thing because the way you want me
to play now is not I'm not good enough
then better you put the other players so
I was direct and open and we spoke
normal normal conversation because I
never had a problem with a coach in a
professional way so the case with him
was the first time I
had I had not discussions because we
didn't even come there like a problem
without knowing knowing the problem and
he said in the end which was cool don't
worry I take care of this I was like
okay cool everything is done next game I
know I'm on the bench said okay no
problem and I'm not the type that would
go to the coach why am I not play why am
I not playing you should play me because
remember I come
from hard work you get what you work for
so for me working hard I would get and
not I need to play I want to play cuz
it's not I get my my my proof of playing
because I prefer you hate me but I play
then I know why I play because I'm good
second game
bench third game bench said okay and now
I'm getting pumped up because obviously
I need to do more to show
myself but I noticed it was not about me
performing anymore it was I think my
opinion he felt offended for me saying
to him I needed more space and the way I
wanted to to play punish which is okay
yeah which is okay he's the coach bad
results he leaves player stays and I
respect that but be open to me be direct
to me so we understand each
other fourth game bench and then I
started to make noise because it's not
okay for me anymore now I'm on the bench
and I have on I'm on the bench because
of a situation I created not by my own
ER how do you say by my own choice
because of the people above him because
for them I was a big
investment and the fourth game I bring
my Ferrari and I bring the end of
Ferrari and I knew it would create
another situation so I parked the car in
front of his office so you with me I
with you that was my motto you parked it
in front of his office in front of his
office I said this
is you want to play with fire I'll bring
you fire but I will burn you but
obviously he's the coach because what
punish most the players player if he
doesn't play because obviously you want
to play but the boss is the coach but in
that moment I understood this will not
be okay because there is something how
did he react to you parking your Ferrari
outside he would not say nothing to me
because he would avoid me but then I
came a the strange thing is I would go
in
a in the breakfast we have a breakfast
area where both of us would come I go in
he would go up and go out of the
room on the field he would never connect
with me like this because you can
connect
by passing each other then you start to
talk without looking for it because I
can pass you on the street oh what's up
P everything okay you know you
understand so we would go against each
other he would take a whole round and go
around me and then I noticed something
was more than just the player because
was too strange is that why you use the
phrase cow but no balls yeah because he
would not confront his whatever problem
he had and he would use his right guide
to
resolve H his problem and probably he
would say now I don't talk about it and
is him still have it in the head him
still talking about it when this will
come out but you give me the question
and I answer your question so he need
not me still think about it it's me only
answering it came to a head there a
dressing room incident after Bara lost
inter uh and it's alleged that you threw
a training kit box across the room yeah
is that true versus him yeah did you hit
him no he didn't hit how did he how did
he react it was a message no he stepped
out of the locker room he would not
confront me he would not confront me
like I see him because I follow football
I see him in the press conferences now
and that saying his thing this didn't
happen here so maybe
become bigger men now have you spoken to
him since he left no no we
met we met uh when when I was in United
he was obviously in
city so you pass the
players but I would not see him there
and this is not me looking for him or
something because for me is the past
because what happened happened you
cannot go back and change you grow from
that you become different from that you
get experience from that but what I know
his his closest friend will stay out of
the out in the hall and wait for me to
pass and when I pass he would come out
and the funny thing is if I would see
him nothing would happen because for me
I'm a man I take it as a man if I have a
problem I resolve it if he's watching
this interview what would you say he
would say I still think about it still I
I am crying no I think he's amazing
coach don't get me wrong I think he's
amazing coach what he's doing he changed
the game 100% he's being very successful
as a man as a man I see him do some
press conference I see him he has been
stepping up so he's not he's not the one
I know I mean that I met so I'm happy
for him I mean remember we share the
same dream we work I was a professional
player he was a professional player so I
don't want any harm for him dislike or
like still we we we share the same dream
you cannot hate a person because of the
situation like that he thinks about him
I think about me so so like I said he's
a coach I'm a player so I think about me
he think about him he has his
responsibility I mine the difference is
I resolve my problem if I have a problem
so if he would say to me listen your
nose is too big listen is the last time
we meet you're not happy I go I resolve
it I didn't know that's my still until
today I don't know what what the problem
was you think you should have the
courage to tell you no he shouldn't he
should run
away